See that bright object in
the sky that's Andromeda.
The closest major galaxy to our Milky Way
and the most distant thing you can see
with the naked eye and it's racing towards
us at the rate of 110 kilometers per
second.
Eventually 4 billion years from now and
drama will merge with our Milky Way in a
huge galactic collision.
But what if these galaxies
where to collide tomorrow?
What all the stars and planets
suddenly plow into each other?
Could our solar system survive this
massive crash and what would this galactic
light show looked like from earth?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if the Milky
Way and the Andromeda galaxy collided.
There are at least 100 billion
galaxies in the observable universe,
all colliding with each
other. Larger galaxies merge
about every 9 billion years,
while smaller ones slam into
each other even more often. Wait,
what about dark energy?
Isn't this hypothesized force pulling
the universe and everything in it apart?
It's your is for nearby galaxies though.
Gravity takes over and drama and
the Milky Way are no exception.
They both contain central supermassive
black holes that will eventually mesh the
two star systems together.
Imagine if that gigantic
collision were to happen tomorrow.
What would that look like?
And drama is pretty far away.
It couldn't just overcome a distance of
two and a half million light years in a
single day.
Let's assume that somehow the supermassive
black hole in the center of the Milky
Way increased its gravitational pull
on Andromeda's black hole and the big
crunch happened 4 billion years
earlier than expected. What's next?
First, there would be no
milky way and no Andromeda.
The two spiral galaxies would become
a totally different type of galaxy and
elliptical one you can call the
new galaxy Macomeda or milk dramas,
whichever one you prefer. Once Andromeda
invaded milky waste personal space,
the sun and our entire solar system
would be forced to the outskirts of the
newly formed Galaxy 26,000
light years further away,
and that's the best case
scenario. In the worst case, one,
we might end up in a galactic Siberia,
160,000 light years away
from Macomeda Center.
What about all the stars in both galaxies?
Would they collide with each other?
Some of them would,
but even though milkyway counts around
250 billion stars and Andromeda drama has
over a trillion of them.
All the stars are separated
by light years of empty space.
It's unlikely that many of
them would merge. Instead,
they'd just get scattered into different
orbits. Ooh, I forgot to mention.
We invited a third galaxy to this party,
the triangular galaxy or m 33 a
smaller satellite galaxy of Andromeda.
This is shaping up to be a massive
galactic Mashup for us earthlings.
This would look just incredible.
The bright core,
the new super galaxy with
set the night sky, a blaze.
Eventually the two supermassive black
holes at the center of these galaxies
would come so close to each other that
they themselves would merge all the gas
taken up by this monstrous black hall
would form a Bright Quasar at the center
of the galaxy. Another spectacular
show for us here on earth.
Too bad in reality, our planet won't
live long enough to see any of it.
By the time Andromeda
slams into the Milky Way,
the sun would have already turned into
a red giant and swollen it up the entire
earth. But that's a story
for another. What if.